he's hit at least two threes in 16 of
their first 23.
lonzo boy four-point play he's going to
the line looking for the four-point play
the difference look at his feet when his
feet are set and he won
twos into that three big bucket get a
three-point game
now on the hesitation blocked away
alonzo
boys lonzo doing a good job with her
spiel at the defensive end
you see him time russell westbrook's
finger roll at the rim another second
chance opportunity
good take blocked away by zion pells
have numbers
bledsoe he's got the lob for lonzo
he must watch tv when this team turns
defense to offense
he gets i'm not saying it's a foul or
it's not a foul
what i'm saying is man
i'm sorry that's a good read by bled i'm
sorry i'm i'm still kind of going on
this
well where zion's bounced around
right at the other end and then you're
gonna call it touch right
jackson kicks it out to morant john
moran of 35 percent
three-point shooter misfiring great long
bass
and that's what they need from him
three-point shooting
williamson with the flush and some
pyrotechnics at the other end
reed for three rattles out
j mack nearly came in and took the
rebound away from four white jerseys
ball at it again
that one even more ridiculous is
so athletically gifted i mean look you
got guys are even anticipating it he's
just
filling and by the way
in order to be in that position you
can't be playing a lot of defense
nobody accounted for beasley or make it
rather deangelo russell
[Applause]
i don't want to pass that is almost a
full court lob
man here's westbrook from the foul line
can't get it and rebounded by ball who
is averaging
about six boards per game how about that
wow oh my goodness the rim
and the entire stanchion is still moving
we expect zion
williamson initially to be a force in
transition anytime he's in space
this is what he's capable of just watch
the rim in the aftermath of this finish
first of all
perfectly placed pass the only guy who
could catch that was lonzo was a great
challenge defensively
just watch the rim moving at the end of
this to get some sense
of the force
[Music]
out of head to heart back to holiday
derrick rose off the high screen with
morris looking for another triple
and good box out passed by josh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he was grabbing that rebound he knew
what that ball was going
excellent delivery by lonzo ball griffin
with a head of steam here's galloway
he's been their best offensive player in
the second half
look at that pass down court how about
lonzo ball
from one end to the other a touchdown
performance spotlight well it's on the
play that happened in the first half we
didn't get a chance to show it
then but we're showing it now where
alonzo created a
sensational behind the back pass after
almost turning the ball
over the hustle and look at that pass
[Applause]
miles bridges and malik both played very
well in the first half
they come in off the bench and lonzo
ball
got to the rim a couple of transitions
dunks but that one right there
good ball handling splits the double
team
and throws it down
[Applause]
[Music]
fall off the screen lonzo bringing
that smoke
what luke walton and the lakers want him
to do turns the corner and attacks
my goodness grown man punching by the
young fellow
losing streak on the road during this
lonzo as he rises and throws it down
with one hand
boy
[Applause]
who puts together a little highlight
finish
who's a bad decision taken by chandler
harris ahead of the pass
rejecting lonzo does that
a lot he does not give up on play ball
harris thinks i got this one
lonzo says no the airball is taken out
of the air sacramento with all the
momentum until
steals it away carter trying to play
defense lonzo off the board oh
randall that was the luckiest absolutely
the luckiest basket they will get this
month
volkswagen takes us through the glass to
show that pass
off the glass to julius and somehow
he controlled it pretty well yeah he got
awfully lucky on this one
awfully lucky lucky on that one
he gets into what i call no man's land
where the big doesn't want to come out
to get him
and he pulls up she's the easiest look
out look out lonzo
wow lonzo ball chain where'd you go
kimba
and look at what's that finish yeah show
me some emotion
i like it normally very stoic
here's about a three second differential
it would be tough to get the last one
bob underneath the kuzma nice it's
lebron with the rebound by ball and down
court perfectly thrown to ingram for two
what a throw
what a pass by ball who's got seven
assists
as fast again that's pretty good as soon
as you get the rebound
he knew that a little bit pace has been
pretty good here
jared jack drives tried to get it to
canter couldn't hold on
here's caldwell polk porzingis in
pursuit and ball throws it down
what a pass from caldwell polk and lonzo
ball with the finished lakers by
two and lonzo ball doing a little bit of
everything for his team
259 remaining third period lakers by
3.87 how about that backboard had
53 of the 104 points made
brewer loves it somehow stuffed it
yeah down mason gets hung up on the
screen brook lopez does a nice job and
you can see carly stein a little bit
close
slow to close to commit to that his
entire career up until this year
kick it ingram on its way he can't score
[Applause]
he should get a rebound and an assist on
that he should and he will
shot was missed by ingram and he knows
brooke is there just tap it to him
beautiful play
lay it up lay it in we're tied at
nine
and ingram the rebound
down toward feed nance jr plus the foul
lonzo ball these are the type of plays
that become contagious don't try to do
too much
frozen on point
full length pass to nance
acknowledge it